recent security scares at big events are
fresh on New Yorkers minds as millions
gather for tomorrow's March at world
Pride two and a half million people
they're expected to line that parade
route about a hundred fifty thousand
marchers are expected to participate in
the LGBTQ celebration the March is so
popular organizers extended the route by
more than half a mile this year David
Berg knows shows us how police plan to
protect it it's all hands on deck as the
incident commander for world Pride chief
Rodney Harrison has a lot of ground to
cover for Sunday's March this is one of
them more narrow streets in the city he
told us there is no credible threat that
has been directed at world Pride
attendees tell us they're a bit wary but
not overly concerned I do think it's
important that we do have a police
presence because climate that we
currently live people are mindful of
recent events there was a shooting this
month that injured four people at a
Toronto Raptors rally days earlier there
was panic amid a false report of a
shooting that had happened at the gay
pride parade in Washington DC and in
2016
a gunman killed 49 people at a gay
nightclub in Orlando Florida those who
come to world Pride this weekend will
see police everywhere how close would
you say a police officer may be to them
there's going to be thousands of cops
out here there gonna be an arm's reach
the NYPD is deploying officers with
rifles to deter potential terrorists
there will be dogs sniffing for bombs
sand filled trucks to block off streets
and helicopters and drones watching from
above this is the largest event in the
city throughout the year I mean we've
got people from all around the world
that are gonna be here relations between
police and the LGBTQ community in New
York City are dramatically different
than they were 50 years ago when police
sparked riots by raiding the Stonewall
Inn earlier this month
NYPD's Commissioner James O'Neal decided
to apologize the actions taken by the
NYPD were wrong plain and simple
since then the Commissioner consulted
with members of the gay community to
keep them posted on the security plans
for the week light you need ice you need
ice out there to make sure too
because there are people that out there
unfortunately that wish to do us harm
you say who wish to do us harm
and I noticed the us you are not gay but
it's almost as if you you sort of take
this personal well I do I think I have
to I mean you have thousands of cops you
have millions of people attending from
all around the world this is this is
something we get through together for
CBS this morning Saturday on David
Beckmann
in New York City